i mean
we were as you mentioned canceled and
people from all over the world uh you
know europe and mexico
and and australia and canada and india
and japan and malaysia just
started voicing their opinion uh
and and banding together and it was just
such a cool thing to know that people of
all races and all genders and all sexual
orientation and
we have fans that go from eight to
eighty
eight seems a little young for our show
but you know teens around
and um and it it
it was great i mean it was so nice to
have that like global embrace
of knowing that it wasn't like
people in corporate positions pushing
for a certain show
it was literally the people speaking and
voting
for a show that they felt uh represented
them
and made them feel less alone which and
inspires them which i think the best
media does it makes you feel like
we are all in this together and we're
not
islands and we're part of the human
community and so to me
um the best storytelling is really
brings people together and is very
inspiring so going to work after that i
i my heart was so full and especially
for me in particular i don't play like a
cool character like i'm not
an angel i'm not a demon i have no
celestial powers
i'm just a scientist and i would go to
these comic cons and girls would dress
up and cosplay my character
and have forensic gloves and have a
forensic jacket and have a forensic bun
and i was so tickled because these girls
weren't dressing up like
storm or they weren't dressing up like
you know a squirrel
like they black widow they were dressing
up like
a scientist which is something that they
could become or the teacher say hey i
show clips of lucifer
of you in the lab because you make
science cool and you're a woman of color
in stem which i think is so neat so
i am i'm it's such a good feeling